new technology aimed at making your life
easier is being unveiled this morning in
Las Vegas it includes technology that
opens a door for your dog when you're
not home okay and a device that
translates 20 different languages in
your ear in real time right CES
introduces the latest innovations to the
public at a massive trade show every
year more than 4,500 companies including
startups and industry powerhouses like
Samsung showcased their new products
Bryan Cooley from our partners at C net
is there lucky him Brian good morning
what do you have with you I'm at the toy
store yeah so first of all let me show
you this really interesting smart jirobo
this is from a company called Waverly
labs they call it the Ambassador it's
not an inner it's an over ear you'd wear
this over your ear and it comes in a kit
of two you give this to someone else who
speaks a different language now while
both of you guys are wearing this all
you've got to do is click on it I'm in
Las Vegas good morning yes yes and it
translates automatically across
languages to two people great when
you're traveling you just have a phone
in your pocket that app sends it to the
cloud for translation 180 bucks for two
of these and again you give it to
someone else on maybe a cab driver maybe
a restaurant or maybe someone in a
business meeting it's a really
interesting thing and it's really small
it's part of this vanguard of smart he
rebels 180 bucks for a pair of those and
have you ever taken a selfie and your
arm wasn't long enough to get everybody
in as the sticks are the worst right
selfie sticks are so dead in 2020 right
so here's what we got Gail you got this
thing called the air pics from a company
called air selfie this is it looks like
a drone it's not it's an aerial camera
so you can get this thing going and you
just say go ahead and get a picture of
me it takes off it's not a camera now
it's framing me up with a facial
recognition camera and once it gets me
framed it takes the shot sends it to my
phone and it comes back and lands
automatically nothing else you have to
do the best part is you don't have to
learn to be a drone pilot and it's a
hundred bucks it's a very inexpensive
lightweight accessory you wouldn't use
it for every photo but for those ones
where you want to get the family in on a
vacation shot that's
this is gonna get those Ryan what's in
your arm won't get it done right what's
the coolest new robot you've seen from
Charmin if you can believe that they
work with a robotics lab to build this
guy called the roll BOTS it's a little
tongue in cheek to be sure but it goes
after a very interesting ethic this is a
robot that will bring you a roll of
pre-loaded fresh toilet paper when you
get in that situation where you know
where you're sitting and guess what's
out and there's not another roll you can
reach we've all been there does it track
see right have you tried it there's a
lot of week left and so it follows you
to your phone and says I know where you
are and you summon it and it brings you
some toilet paper it also assumes very
accurately that we're always sitting on
the can with our phones so that's kind
of interesting that's very smart stuff
they're uninteresting yeah interesting
dog we saw is called the Tom bond I
don't have you here with me but it's for
$400 robotic dog you might say okay
here's Cooley with another robot this
one's interesting it's not meant to be a
cute little pet it is that an amazingly
lifelike but it's intended for animal
assisted therapy for dementia patients
who really respond to animals well I've
met with groups that use dogs for
post-traumatic stress disorder paws for
purple hearts uses that but real dogs
are sentient beings take a lot of
training this could be scaled very
quickly also great for working with
prisoners who need to have a sense of
relationship and responsibility with a
living creature animal therapy is really
interesting robotic dogs may fill that
gap it'll be four hundred bucks when it
comes out later this year you don't have
to walk it Brian I really like that idea
Brian let's talk about macaques talk
about makeup and finding the perfect
lipstick color because I hear they have
something that will help you do that
have you tried that one
yeah L'Oreal has got something well I
didn't try it personally but that may
come later l'oréal's got something
called purr so yeah it's a little Tower
and you put some cartridges of different
lipstick colors in when I saw it I go
wait a minute that's the paint mixing
machine from Home Depot that's basically
what it is but it creates lipstick
colors using an app that gives you the
perfect shade but why I'm really
interested in it is because they can
also blend in custom skincare so you
look good but you're also doing
something good
you and it's a custom mix just for you
all right some really cool stuff we like
[Music]
you